[Music]
the coronavirus keeps evolving
as it spreads it's mutating taking on
new characteristics that can make it
harder to fight
new variants found in south africa and
the uk are more contagious
straining health services
[Music]
this mutation has led to more cases than
we've seen ever before
numbers that alas cannot be explained
away by the meteoric rise
in testing japan
is trying to isolate a new variant from
brazil there's no proof
any of them are any deadlier but the
virus is constantly changing
and could eventually make vaccines less
effective
we're watching evolution take place
right in front of our eyes the new
coronavirus is doing everything it can
to survive
becoming cleverer at jumping from host
to host the hope is that we're doing
everything we can to survive
many big economies are back in lockdown
including south africa
this isn't a waiting room it's the
treatment room for covered 19 patients
at the hospital
in kaya leecher one patient calls out to
tell us she's been sitting and waiting
for three days waiting for a bed to
become free
next door he's on two weeks to sit on a
chair
so we put them on the on the stretcher
and they are all oxygen
doctor susan mukhon kole has been
working here for nine years
but the pandemic is pushing him to his
limits a third of his colleagues
here have already had the virus how do
you feel to see your hospital level
sometimes you feel powerless because you
don't have enough
space sometimes we don't have enough
oxygen point we need to improvise and
see how we can split
one point into two to give oxygen
sometimes you have to choose
to do you give first the oxygen and we
should wait
that that sometimes is very stressful
on average one person dies with covered
19 in the hospital
every day there's a small room next door
with
somewhat better facilities for acute
patients
waiting for an intensive care bed at
another hospital
but the local health minister admits
that not everyone can get
an icu bed most are already full
if the person qualifies for the icu
to defense but remember even using prior
profits for icu entry there's always a
scoring index
the house is on fire
south africans are battling a new more
infectious variant of the virus
the fast spread has led to tighter
lockdown measures
including a ban on alcohol sales and the
closure of beaches
the police are struggling with enforcing
them
only patients over the age of 45 are now
being tested at the state clinics
the demand is overwhelming
here in virologist wolfgang price's
laboratory every second
test is positive the peak of the second
wave is expected in south africa in mid
january but even after that experts
expect
further waves i fear that neither the
current enormous search that we are
experiencing now
nor the arrival of a vaccine sometime
into halfway through 2021 for a
small proportion of the population will
be able to make a big difference
the government has said it's already in
talks with vaccine manufacturers
but there are no details yet
emma hodcroft is a molecular
epidemiologist
how much hope should we be putting in
these vaccines
so the good news is is that your body
learns to recognize many parts of the
virus when it's exposed to these
vaccines or when you've been infected
with sars cov2
so even if the virus changes a little
bit the hope is your body will still
learn to recognize it
and be able to mount a really good
protective response however it's going
to take some time to get enough people
vaccinated
so that we can really see this impact on
the number of cases
and it's important to remember that most
vaccines need two doses before they're
fully effective
so we really need people to keep using
other
non-pharmaceutical protections like hand
washing mask wearing and being aware of
aerosol transmission
until we're certain that the vaccines
are helping us to keep the case numbers
low
but why all the concern then about these
mutations
uh considering that they're so slight
the the boss of bayern tech told dw
that they're only one percent and and
that wouldn't affect
his vaccine's effectiveness so
why are we also worried i think one
thing that is important to keep in mind
is that a lot of the fear about vaccines
is hypothetical
certainly it's possible that the virus
could change enough that your body
doesn't recognize it anymore
and then your protection could be
impacted but until we have a reason to
believe that some of these mutations are
really
having that effect on real people who've
been vaccinated
i think it's important to keep our worry
a little bit in check
now certainly there are some mutations
that have some concerns from early
studies
but importantly these have all been done
in the lab and it's very hard to predict
what the impact of a lab study actually
means in a full-size human and a
full-size population
so i think until we really have evidence
that these mutations
will impact vaccine efficacy we
shouldn't be too worried
what sort of time frame are we looking
at i mean i mean could it speed up the
the rate of its mutations
so luckily sars kobe 2 has a pretty
consistent mutation rate we actually
call
viruses mutations kind of clock-like
because they're so predictable in how
often they happen
so we don't expect the virus to mutate
faster but one thing we do want to keep
in mind is that while we have high case
numbers we're maximizing the viruses
ability to explore
different people different immune
systems and maybe
be put under interesting and unique
selection pressures
and this might mean that we see a
mutation start rising
in prominence because it's been in one
of these unique situations
we can never completely eliminate that
this might happen but clearly the fewer
people that are getting infected
the less room the virus has to play in
these different environments
and hopefully the less chance that we
see a mutation that we'd really rather
not see
and emma tell me more about what we know
about these
mutations making people's antibodies
less effective and neutralizing the
virus so there's been a few studies on
some of the mutations that are found
in both the 501y
v1 and 501y v2 variants those are the
variants predominantly found in the uk
and in south africa and the news has
been mixed here so what
scientists do in these cases is they
take the virus and then they expose it
to what we call the serum the antibodies
of people who've already had sars kobe
2.
for some of these mutations it looks
like there isn't any impact on how well
those antibodies work
for some of the other mutations in some
cases it seems like it might reduce the
efficacy
but again these are for single mutations
and oftentimes a few people's serum so
we really need to keep doing studies to
find out not only
how widespread might this effect be but
does this actually mean that it impacts
your immunity in a full-grown human
rather than just in a petri dish
and whether this is something we really
need to be concerned about
is that why tracing or sequencing has
become so important
so i do think that one thing that these
new variants have really brought to the
fore
is the importance of genomic
surveillance and sequencing
we can only tell that a new variant
might be responsible for a rise in cases
if we have sequences that tell us that
that virus has a different genetic
makeup
and importantly because that virus has
this unique kind of fingerprint of
mutations
we can track how it's spread around the
world as well
which is why we know that this uk and
south african variants
are in different places around the world
this is really important as not only
does it mean that we can identify
variants
and the mutations that might be
impacting things like transmission
we can also understand how the virus is
spreading and
whether we can protect countries from
getting it or how we can contain it once
it's there
now the number of sequences countries
are generating is really different from
country to country
and it would be great to see a more
concerted effort to make sure that we
have regular sequences coming in
from every country around the world emma
holdcroft molecular epidemiologist
thank you very much for being on the
show today
and let's bring in our science
correspondent derek williams he's been
looking at your questions surrounding
code 19.
[Music]
why are members of the same household
not always infected with the coronavirus
after one member is infected
this is an aspect of the pandemic that
puzzled scientists from the start
you know it it kind of makes sense to to
reformulate this question to something
like
um if this is a novel pathogen that no
one
had ever been exposed to before then we
should have all been equally
likely to get it and and to get it
equally bad
right i mean especially in a shared
space
like a household but we apparently
aren't um
one possible reason why is that
prior exposure to other coronaviruses
might possibly lower risks for some
people so
their immune systems were maybe a little
forearmed
then of course there are also plenty of
people who are
asymptomatic even when they do catch the
disease they just appear
for all intents and purposes to be
healthy and they remain
undetected even though they're carrying
sars cove to
and could maybe give it to others but we
should also flip this question
and look at the other half of the
equation how contagious
someone is so not how come
some people don't catch the virus but
instead
why some of us seem to give it more
easily
to others there's some scientific
consensus that for
reasons that remain unclear a subgroup
of people
often called a super spreaders or super
emitters could be driving most of the
transmission
um some experts think just 10 to 20
percent
of people who catch covid19 pass it
along to up to 80 percent
of all subsequent cases so in other
words
if your spouse or your child has the
virus but
for whatever reason isn't a super
spreader
they're less likely to give it to you
especially if you follow isolation
protocols
that said there's broad agreement that
during
lockdowns transmission still happens
more within
homes than anywhere else simply because
sharing a household with someone who has
covet 19
increases your exposure so statistically
at least
you're still more likely to get it from
a family member
than you are from a stranger